people aren't afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner you'll
record a video but you'll never release
it you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still have more
than made the money that you invested
into any of the stuff that I'm doing but
at the same time it's still this fear I
want to attack the fear I teach myself
to attack the fear and I think you
should too and even just attacking it
for the sake of attacking it is good
it's good because you're building
strength because you're pushing your
comfort zone because you're getting
better because you're growing that's
worth something that's a ton of value
because if you can conquer your fear of
doing this one thing that translates to
every year of your life if you teach
yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere that fear of
taking your phone and recording a video
in public on the street these fears that
seem like nothing they show up
everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business and so
learning to tackle them especially in
low stakes starts building the muscle
rule number two believe you go as far as
you believe you can go when the people
around you say you're crazy when you're
putting in massive effort but you're not
getting the results where you sit alone
and wonder did you just make the biggest
mistake of your life by starting this
business that is the time when most
people quit and you need to believe more
because if you love this thing if you
know that it's going to impact people
and you give up too soon you will regret
for the rest of your life knowing that
you were capable of more and you just
quit on it a little too early so I look
at my new book as an example I did my
tour across America met with
entrepreneurs all across America and
found that people were struggling with
the same thing they want to know how do
I find what my purpose is and turn it
into a lucrative business
every city that I went to even though
that was not the topic I was covering it
came up over and over and over and over
again 23 different cities and so I
thought I'm going to write a book on
this this is going to be my next book
I'm going to take people through the
process because my process works and it
helped people live in in 10 15 minutes
and they're getting they're getting new
ideas and and results and here we go
like they understand what path they need
to take finally they have Clarity on
what to do next and so I told my agent
and my lit agent like this is the next
book I want to write
we told Publishers this is the next book
I'm going to write
and from the start it's been this big
pull it's been it's been fighting it's
we don't like the title we don't like
the concept no we're not going to
publish it no we're not going to publish
it and I want to do it by January
because I want to do my next tour across
the rest of the United States East Coast
Texas Mexico I want to do my next tour
so I want to have my book in stores by
that time and it's been this rough slog
where if I didn't believe in myself that
this was so important with the people
who are looking at it saying no we don't
like this concept now it's been written
before now this method we don't believe
in
it's easy to quit it's easy to give up
it's easy to say forget it I just know
that it's gonna work
I know that the process helps people
I've seen it with my eyes across 23
cities over 90 days
I wrote the draft of the book and I gave
it to some beta readers and the number
one piece of advice from people who've
read both my books the year one word and
then this like this is this is the
better book this is the best book you've
written so far including my
self-published ones and so what do I do
I've got these people who are my
audience who love it and then these
people who aren't my audience but who
make decisions saying now we don't
believe in it
I'm not gonna call it
quit I gotta keep going I gotta do my
tour
there's there better be some crazy good
reason for me not to do my tour right
even if I have to self-publish it now
I'm pretty close at making my deal
making it all happen and and getting
timelines and all that but we don't have
a signed contract yet and anything can
happen
we're pushing the timelines because I'm
pushing the timelines because otherwise
this thing could drag on forever when
you have an idea that you love that you
know can have a huge impact
that's just taking longer than you hoped
it would when people are telling you
that it's crazy and that it's stupid and
that who are you to go off and do this
thing
you love it you have to double down on
it you have to go in on it you have to
be open to getting help but if that door
closes you try to find another one and
that's the story of every successful
person you're trying to do something
different rule number three become a
shark you haven't become a shark yet
because you haven't decided that your
mission is important enough now being a
shark doesn't mean that you have to
become aggressive violent and angry it
means that you're pushing to be the best
in your industry a true leader someone
who makes a difference and it starts
with your mission raise the level of how
important your mission feels to you and
your entire life changes so I look at my
mission as an example I want to solve
the world's biggest problem it's never
going to happen I'm trying to solve the
biggest problem I think in the world
which is that lack of belief in yourself
the untapped potential that's what I
wake up every day trying to do and the
more that I put myself in a position of
this thing matters what I do really
really really matters the more I could
put myself in that mind frame the bigger
my thinking becomes the Bolder I get as
a human and as an entrepreneur and I
look at the path that I've taken over
the past X number of years I look at
being able to collaborate with someone
like Eric Thomas when he gave a shout
out in his video that would have been
something I wouldn't have thought of
when I first started on YouTube I look
at the relationships I built with people
like Tony Robbins and Gary vaynerchuk
and Grant Cardone the people that we
profile Tony Robbins I took the people
on my team to go see him at Unleash the
Power Within I brought five I think of
my people down and we're sitting up in
the cheap seats and then a year later a
year later he invited me as his personal
guest to sit right down in the front row
chairman invited seating and I'm going
back I leave tomorrow I don't know when
this video goes up but I leave tomorrow
for Dallas to do it again
it's wild
right like it doesn't feel like that
stuff is possible
comes from shift in the value of your
your mission I deserve it because what
I'm doing is solving a real problem
and we often feel like we're not capable
of doing these great things and we
downplay our role and we downplay how
important our mission is and we downplay
what we think we can do that's what
needs to shift that's what needs to
change you need to feel like the work
you do matters you need to feel like the
mission you're on means something can
have a big impact and if you're
approaching life in that way everything
in your business changes rule number
four never quit on something that you
love as long as you love it you have to
keep going you cannot quit maybe one day
somebody does throw you a bunch of money
and you can stop sleeping in your office
or maybe it's just a slow grind up and
it takes you 10 years to become an
overnight success you'll never know how
long it will take you to be successful
but what you do know is that if you quit
on something that you love you will end
up regretting it for the rest of your
life as long as you love it you have to
keep going you can't quit so look at my
story it wasn't easy being an
entrepreneur girl growing up that's why
I do so much to help entrepreneurs
because I don't want you guys to
struggle as much as I did in my first
real business when I was 19 I had to
decide between earning a hundred
thousand dollars a year and traveling
around the world in my dream job versus
owning 30 of a company making 300 bucks
a month and being unsure if anything is
going to work out or not and I decided
that I had to keep going I had to try
because I didn't want to end up being 85
years old looking back and said I never
did it I never went for it I would
rather no one fail than not know because
the things that you regret are rarely
the things that you do it's the things
that you didn't do the things that you
had a chance to do you had an
opportunity you thought about it you
felt it but then you back down because
you're afraid those are the things that
you regret that's what you regret most I
didn't want that to happen
but starting off my business wasn't easy
I struggled I suck I I made it harder on
myself because I told my friends that I
was living the entrepreneur life and I
couldn't hang out with them meanwhile
that twenty dollars was just too
expensive for me to go out and have beer
with them right I isolated myself I made
myself lonely
I felt worthless as a human being and
the worst day of my life came when I
told my business partner that I quit on
him that it was just too difficult that
I couldn't keep going that I needed to
feel like I was contributing that that
my time meant something that all this
work I was putting into something I just
need to feel valuable again that I was
contributing to something
when you wake up every day and you're
working and it's just not getting
results it can be real hard to keep
going
and so I told him that I quit I hung up
the phone and then just started crying
and the next day I woke up and I just
thought I can't I can't I can't quit on
this not yet I haven't given everything
I've got
because I felt like
in a year and two years and five years
and 20 years I would look back and
regret that I gave up
if I knew that I gave everything I had
and it didn't work out I was okay with
the failure
it was just an idea of that thing
lingering that I could have given a
little bit more that I still like this
thing and I needed to see it through and
I and I didn't that I quit on it I knew
that would eat me up forever
and so I had to get up that next day and
tell myself I'm not gonna quit yet
I just have to find a different way to
stand what I've tried so far has not
worked it has not worked I'm making zero
money
well 300 bucks a month
but it's not working out and I hate
myself I hate my life I hate how I feel
about myself I have to find a different
way to stand
and that energy allowed me to keep going
that energy allowed me to then ask
myself who else has done this before and
I looked at Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and that started the
path up for my business and then two
years later I sold my company it
happened pretty quick
all because I refused to quit on the
thing that I knew I needed to see
through also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five unlock your talent you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something but instead of being world
class at that thing you settle for being
just above average at something that you
should not be doing Albert Einstein once
said everybody is a genius but if you
judge a fish by its ability to climb a
tree it will believe its whole life that
it is stupid that's most people's
problems you are a fish and you're
trying to climb a tree instead of going
and being great at swimming this is the
exact problem that I'm on a mission to
solve so I recently had a young
entrepreneur come to one of my Toronto q
a meetups that are free that I host
every week and he said Evan I have a
problem I'm trying to decide between
what my parents want me to be which is
an architect and what I feel uh yearning
towards which is being a musician and I
don't know what to do
I know how to decide I don't know how
I'm going to be a success as a musician
I don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and this is clearly defined
path for how to do it and he's afraid
and I think that's so many people
there's a safe perfect path that has
been designed that people have done
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever or this is new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people and you do what they want
you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it
it's never been easier to actually be
yourself and build a business and have
success being uniquely you right this
was not open to your parents and
definitely not your grandparents the
ability to be an entrepreneur on the
side making money using your phone is
something that your grandparents don't
understand it's just it's totally wild
and so you are a unique individual right
you are I am we all are you have unique
interests personality traits belief
systems you're unique you need to do
something unique if you are unique you
need to do something unique if you're
stuck doing the same thing that somebody
else wants you to do you're never going
to be happy now there may be some
alignment you may not absolutely hate
the job that you're at but you know
you're capable of more you're Michael
Jordan you are the Michael Jordan of
something you're a genius and absolute
bona fide genius at something this is
why I think it's the world's greatest
problem this is why I do what I do every
single day in making this content videos
for you because I want to unlock people
hope hopefully more than one at a time
but even if it's just one person who
watches this video and gets unlocked I'm
pumped because I think if everybody is
off doing the thing that they are a
genius at man I want to live in that
world rule number six keep up with the
change every time YouTube updates their
algorithm you should be pumped anytime
Facebook LinkedIn Instagram makes an
update you should celebrate because this
is your chance to win as an entrepreneur
everybody else who's ahead of you who've
made it on the old algorithm before the
update happened they're complaining and
wishing that it goes back to the way
that it used to be it's not going back
and the faster you can get on that train
and understand how the new algorithm
works you are going to soar past
everybody else whenever something new
comes along it's gonna happen guys the
new things that are coming along is only
going to speed up there's going to be
more new things not fewer new things
every time a new thing comes along you
don't necessarily need to be the first
one on it I'm not saying that you have
to go off and try everything
but when something new is coming along
embrace it because this is the future
right so many people say well I'm not on
social media oh that's for the kids
you've got to get on it if you're an
entrepreneur you need to be on social
media and not just giving it off to your
kid or your niece or your nephew to do
you you need to understand it doesn't
mean you need to be the best at it but
you need to understand it because this
is not just where marketing is going
it's where marketing is your business is
suffering because you don't understand
how to play the game so Rome wasn't
built in a day but it didn't crumble in
a day either if you're not on social if
you're not taking advantage of new
technologies your business is slowly
starting to crumple and I don't want
that for you rule number seven play to
win people are so afraid to lose that
they don't even try so when you have
nothing when you're at the bottom you've
got nothing to lose
takes as soon as you've won just a
little bit now you risk losing something
and this is where most people back down
and play small for life and so you need
to decide are you playing life to win or
are you playing life afraid to lose so I
look at my YouTube channel as an example
when I started it there was no risk
nobody knew me nobody's watching my
videos I could go and fail didn't make a
difference I could try a whole bunch of
different things whenever the algorithm
changed I got pumped because the people
who are ahead of me were complaining and
would would be romantic and would want
it to go back the way it was and I'm
like hey algorithm change amazing let's
go I'm gonna learn that new thing
but now I've gotten bigger
right now I think I have more views than
anybody in The Entrepreneur Space on
YouTube and it's easy to now be
protective it's easy to say well I built
this thing I don't want to lose and I
hate that I need to I need to destroy
that I want to be constantly losing
constantly testing constantly risking
now not risking at all not not putting
everything on the line just for one
thing but to be willing to test willing
to fail as an example
I split up my channels
I split up my channels into eight
different channels I got an advice from
Matt Gillan he's one of five people who
who I put on my hand as people who I
listened to for YouTube advice right he
was one of the five and another one in
the five said don't do it so I got five
people who I listened to about YouTube
one person says split up your channel
one person says don't do it what do I do
I have to do it just to see because I
know what not swimming my channel looks
like it's what I'm currently doing
but splitting on my channel I won't know
if it's gonna work or not until I
actually go off and do it and so I did
and here's a news flash it's not working
yet right my other channels the most I
think has 8 000 subscribers they have
two around 8 000 subscribers and the
others are are smaller and they're
growing every day and they're getting a
momentum every day but overall my
subscriber growth is down My Views are
down my revenue is down everything is
down it's all down watch time is down
everything is down is it a big failure I
don't know maybe I'm gonna give it more
time and see
I'm gonna give it more time and see it's
a risk right I went from making three
videos a day on one channel to making
one video a day across a couple channels
and then you know once a week on some
channels and we have eight different
channels now it's more headache it's
more management maybe ultimately it will
work out or maybe in six months I'll
come back and say man that was a giant
failure that sucked
but I won't know until they try and
that's that's where you need to risk it
that's where you need to try you need to
see you need to test you need to taste
it rule number eight stop hiding the
reason why you are not further ahead is
you have told yourself that you are not
capable of it that's it and you'll come
up with really smart reasons that are
based in logic as to why you're not more
successful you are a genius you are
excellent and so you'll come up with
really Smart Genius reasons as to why
you are not further ahead right now but
at the end of the day you're just afraid
and you don't think you're capable
that's what I want to change in you
today so I sat down yesterday with an
entrepreneur who is an up and coming
entrepreneur he's had a job for a long
time he's now in his mid 50s and he got
let go from his job and he interviewed
for another job and it didn't feel it
was a quite fit and and he didn't get
the job but he doesn't want to go back
and get another job he wants to now go
do his own thing but there's that
gnawing little voice in your head that
says who am I to do this who am I to be
an entrepreneur who am I to bring value
to others who am I to make money off
this idea why not just go play it safe
and get a job working with somebody else
and his one word was getting down to
saying yes like you have to say yes and
so this is where it's really important
when you know what you stand for when
you know what your core value is
whenever you see it and then you see
your life not aligned with it you're
going to be unhappy if you're unhappy if
you need more boldness more motivation
more confidence more courage look to
your most important core value look look
at what you stand for look at who you
are because if your one word is all
about saying yes to things then you have
to say yes right you have to go off and
do it because otherwise you'll live your
entire life in regret so here he is this
this entrepreneur who's now in his mid
50s who's been let go from his job who's
now trying to start up his own career
his own thing just got his first
speaking gig just getting started with
his YouTube channel and podcasts and
building momentum and that's what it's
all about he has all the skills he has
all the talents he's been in this
industry for decades he knows what he's
doing and yet he's afraid he's afraid
that he's not good enough he's afraid
that's not going to work out he's afraid
that people won't find his expertise his
knowledge valuable and I think that's
most people I think I think everybody's
a genius I think you're a genius I think
you have Michael Jordan level Talent
skills at something you're just doing
the wrong thing and we're afraid you're
afraid to take action you're afraid to
do the thing and so you'll live your
entire life with regret knowing that you
are capable of more you right now know
you're capable of more even if your
friends and family and the people around
you say wow you're doing such a good job
you know you're capable of more and
you're not living up to your potential
it's most people
and why are you not living up to your
potential because you're afraid of what
that means you're afraid of the
obstacles you have to overcome you're
afraid of the difficulties that you have
to go through you're afraid of being
judged you're afraid of a failure
happening and being catastrophic you not
be able to recover you're just afraid
and so we need to crush that we need to
crush that we need to teach yourself
that you do scary things rule number
nine concentrate on your effort most
people don't concentrate long enough on
achieving their goals so what happens
you don't achieve your goals if you're
focused on something and you do it every
day consistently you will eventually get
results but if you're constantly jumping
from one thing to another from one idea
to another from one activity to another
then you'll never actually accomplish
what you're capable of the problem isn't
lack of creativity or ideas or genius
it's a lack of concentration and if
that's you I want to fix it in this
video today so let's take a quick look
at my YouTube journey I started on
YouTube over 10 years ago it's crazy
that it's been that long and I wasn't
very good when I started go back and
watch my first videos or all all still
up there I haven't deleted them you can
go back and watch every single one of
them see how much I sucked I'm an
introvert this is not natural for me it
took a lot of concentration a lot of
focused effort and 6 000 plus videos
later here I am why because I just kept
going because I kept focused on my
mission on my objective it took me 350
videos until I wasn't completely
embarrassed by myself 350 videos I had
to have my sister come come into the
room with the camera focus on me press
record and then leave because I couldn't
film with her in the room and that's my
sister how is this guy gonna be a
YouTuber and be on stage and give
speeches and be a thought leader and
deliver presentations if you can't even
do a simple video with your sister in a
room concentration focused effort that's
the key it's been every single day we've
been uploading videos we've done three
plus videos a day for the past five
years every single day I've been sick
videos went up I broke my neck in two
spots had a concussion videos going up I
lost my voice videos going up all the
time every single day for the past five
plus years it's been at least three
videos across my main Channel now my
multiple channels concentration I'm not
very good at this the point of all this
isn't to brag or say look at me it's
saying that I suck
that if I could do it so can you the
difference is I think a lot of you guys
are way more talented than I am but look
at Alex for example who works for me at
TDS he's just so much more naturally
gifted in front of the camera he's funny
he's charismatic a lot of the stuff that
I'm not and I've been slowly grinding
away getting better in front of the
camera so I think a lot of you guys are
actually better than me or better than
what I was and if if you just kept going
if you just kept working on it you would
you would improve and you would have the
results you're after you're just not
patient enough you're not concentrating
enough you're not putting in the work
every single day
this great story comes to mind that is
great and sad at the same time I was
meeting a friend in Orlando
another influencer
um
six years ago or so
and we met up and he said I'm going to
be the next garyvee
okay great I love it pumped like let's
go I'm I'm just starting my YouTube
career really starting to take off and
he wants to be his thing and he's going
to be the next influencer I love it and
then he posted something about a year
ago or so and he said
you know five years ago I met Evan at
this place in Starbucks in Orlando and I
told him I was gonna be the next garyvee
and he was on his career to build his
YouTube channel and fast forward now and
Evan's got you know a million million
and a half subscribers and I'm still
kind of where I was because I didn't put
in the work
and so that's what I don't want for you
right he just he has talent he's a
genius so are you he just didn't do the
five years of work that I did and he's
someone who's actually I think way more
charismatic than I am and so I don't
want that for you I want you to
concentrate on your effort which will
then lead to results and I'll give you a
three-step process that you can follow
to help you get there Step number one is
flip patience and impatience people have
this really messed up view on patients
and inpatients I think people are often
impatient with the results so you want
the results immediately the human nature
you want it immediately but you're very
patient with yourself if you look at
what you're doing every day like I'll do
that tomorrow you get an idea yeah I'll
start Monday I'll start next week I'll
start and I'll start next year fresh
year start off fresh all that right no
you flip it you flip it
you flip patients and impatience what I
want you to do is have patience with the
results that the results will come and
in patience with yourself that today
matters today you're watching this I
don't know what time it is during the
day you're watching this today matters
what you create today has to mean
something because if you approached
every day with massive impatience for
yourself and your effort and you did
that every day you did the work that you
were proud of yourself for your effort I
promise you that the results are going
to come
but we'll take some time to get to your
big goals
you have big goals right you want to you
want to do something big you have big
Ambitions you don't want just some tiny
little win awesome that's going to take
some time even if you're hustling and
grinding and being proud of your effort
every single day it's going to take some
time so patience with the results and
massive impatience with yourself number
two is think big and act small
this is where I think a lot of
entrepreneurs get tripped up you need to
think big and act small so you have a
big Vision a big mission something that
you want to go off and change the world
my big thinking is I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right it's never
going to happen in my lifetime and yet I
wake up every day trying to tackle it
you want to have a big Vision the
problem with it though for some people
is that it means you don't start because
to make that big Vision happen you need
money you need investors you need camera
gear you need equipment you need a team
me you need all this stuff right just
keeps adding up all the stuff you need
and then you never start that's the
problem the reason why some dummies are
winning off of your idea instead of you
is because they just started because
they acted small so you think big and
that's the motivating dream that you're
chasing down every day and you act small
like what's the smallest thing that I
can do today just to start building
momentum because momentum is a thing
that is missing in most businesses you
have great ideas your Genius you're
talented I love what you're trying to do
it's amazing you need momentum momentum
every single day creating a little bit
more momentum to make that dream come
true think big act small and number
three is schedule for Success look at
your calendar success is your habits
right you want to make sure that your
actions map to your Ambitions the
actions that are in your calendar if you
did those things would help you
accomplish your goals your dreams your
Ambitions so if you're talking about
building a YouTube career amazing show
me in your calendar where every week
you're making time to make YouTube
videos if you want to be an author
awesome I'm pumped show me in your time
show me in your calendar where you've
blocked it out that you're gonna spend
time writing on your book most people
don't do it and then you allow All These
Little Things these distractions to pull
you away from the thing that you want to
be doing you you have to put the big
things into your calendar first and
block off the time and protect that time
and look at it from above and not just
your business your your personal stuff
too what's a good relationship look like
what's a good health situation for
yourself look like right habits put in
your calendar and then step above it and
look at the week that you're about to go
off and do look at your week ahead if
you did those things consistently would
it help you accomplish your goals and
for too many people it's no you're
living in reaction mode to other
people's emergencies and then you never
get to do the thing that you want to do
you got to defend your time you're
scheduled for Success so whatever your
big goals are what if you need to
concentrate on you need to make sure
you're spending an appropriate amount of
time on it so that you get good at it so
you can start getting results and making
the impact that you know you can make
schedule for Success at rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is ignore what others think if you
live your life based off the opinions of
other people you will never do anything
great take a look at who you're worried
people who are not happy with their life
people who never went and took their
shot people who spend their life
complaining instead of trying to change
something is that who you want to be so
worried about what they think about your
decisions if anything you want to do the
exact opposite of what they're telling
you to do you don't want their life so
stop living your life by their rules so
I had an amazing one-on-one with an
entrepreneur yesterday at my q a session
here in Toronto that I do weekly and I
feel for her she's such a talented
amazing gifted entrepreneur and we
talked about your purpose coming from
your pain and she went through some
massive pain that guided her to the
success right now and on her path to
personal development but she's afraid to
share what happened
and she said maybe in a year or two like
give me a year to work on it maybe I'll
share it because she's afraid of what
people will think she's afraid that if
it doesn't work out that she may not be
able to get another job she's afraid of
all these things that people might say
about her if they found her the truth
problem is that's your path I don't care
about what where you're at right now I
need to know where you've come from I
need to know that you look like me I
need to know that your story is like
mine and so by living in the shadows and
being afraid to tell the truth what
you're doing is one not letting people
connect you as a real person right this
fake perfect version of you isn't
something that people can connect to two
you make it so that whatever you went
through it you're telling yourself that
it's it's shameful and you're telling
other people that it's shameful too but
if you come out and talk about what
happened then the people who feel
ashamed about it they now can come out
and say huh I'm not the only one
this happens to other people too I'm a
little bit more normal and three if you
want to build a business if you want to
create a YouTube channel if you want to
have a podcast you want to be an author
you want to write a book that's the
thing that's going to actually help take
you off
that's the thing there was a a great
video that I told her about about a
woman who gained 70 pounds uh from
having a child so she's pregnant she
gained 70 pounds
and she had a 10 pound baby and now she
had 60 pounds of extra
fat on her right 60 pounds so that's a
lot and so she's trying to lose it and
she's working out and she's eaten
healthy and she finally gets down to
having a six-pack apps and looking great
and then somebody noticed that when she
bent over
that that they could see the flaps of
skin when she stood up it was all six
pack but when she bent over there was
flaps of skin and what most people would
have done is deleted that video pretend
like it didn't exist not talk about that
comments right only show the perfect
version look how much weight I lost but
she did something different and said she
said yeah
that's my body now that's what happens
when you gain 70 pounds in pregnancy and
pump out a 10 pound baby
and that became a rallying cry that one
moment of vulnerability of saying hey
I'm still not perfect like look look at
this saggy skin that I still have
that's what brought people to her now
she's not just another mom who lost
weight and did this workout plan and
meal plan right that that connection was
real and now she's built a Million
Dollar Plus business from selling
e-courses and her recipes and everything
else that she goes through that's the
thing
this is your competitive Advantage your
purpose your pain your story is your
competitive Advantage I do not want to
learn from you until I know that you've
been through what I'm going through
I can't relate to that story right I
can't tell that story I can't tell a mom
who gained 70 pounds how to lose weight
that's not my story I can't relate to it
but helping entrepreneurs I can because
I struggled and I suffered and I was
making 300 a month and I was eating the
same bean salad lunch every day and I
celebrated with only McDonald's french
fries because I couldn't afford to buy
it all of it I struggle with with fear
and embarrassment and and shame all of
it I know what it's like I've been
through that and why I do what I do now
is because I want to try to make the
path a little bit easier for the next
generation of entrepreneurs for you I
want you to feel like you're not alone I
want you to feel like there's a place
you can come to with a beautiful
community of believe Nation where we're
supporting each other and this content
every single day across multiple
channels that you can go and digest and
dive into and hopefully hopefully
hopefully make your path just a little
bit easier because I wish I had this
when I was getting started when I was a
19 year old entrepreneur who was
insecure and and ashamed and embarrassed
and not willing to talk to anybody about
the problems I was going through right
that's the thing that will connect
people to you but if you're so afraid of
what people's judgments are going to be
you're never going to get started I
believe humans are built to serve you're
built to serve you want to help other
people it's hardwired into US studies
show that the impact of serving other
people has the same effect on your brain
as food and sex it's hardwired into you
you want to help other people and at the
same time you're afraid of judgment so
how do you help other people if you're
also afraid of judgment it's it's having
your foot on the gas going to break at
the same time you know you're capable of
more but then you just standing on the
same spot it's the worst and so you have
to let go of the opinions of other
people some people may not like what
you're doing that's okay that can't
prevent you from service that can't
prevent you from fulfilling your mission
that can't prevent you from living the
life you want because you're going to be
95 years old looking back on your life
and regretting it knowing you're capable
of more but never taking action now I
have a very special bonus clip that is
around how to ask for help that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three important Landing
questions let's go fun just watching the
video to taking action here we go
question number one whose opinion do you
need to annoy number two where do you
need to stop hiding and number three
what do you love that you will never
quit on you don't want to ask for help
because you're afraid you're afraid that
one they're gonna say no or two that you
are imposing on them either way you're
making a decision from a place of fear
doubt and scarcity it's time to step
into your boldness what would the most
bold version of you do and make yourself
proud so I was on a call this week with
David Bach who is a super successful
author who sold seven million plus books
he's got a new book out called the latte
factor and I was on a call with him
because I said David I want you to be on
YouTube we need your advice your wisdom
your energy on YouTube because you've
got a great message that yes you're
delivering through books but I want to
see it in video format I think it's a
great opportunity to reach people and
because his audience is Millennials you
need to be on YouTube that's where
they're hanging out and and he thanked
me and gave him a whole bunch of advice
on how to get started and he's going to
Florence and I gave him tips on on what
to talk about and how to film and
everything that just pure love for me to
help him and then at the end he said
something that I was uncomfortable with
he said hey Evan how can I help you
you've given me so much you've helped me
with my branding and what I'm trying to
do with YouTube how can I be of service
to you and I said I don't I don't know
man I don't know I don't I don't usually
ask for help I have a hard time asking
for help this is this is a problem not
just not just for you guys watching but
for me too I don't ask enough people for
help and so I said well
um racking my brain I mean the point of
this call wasn't to try to get you to
help me but since you asked I've got a
new book that I'm working on right I'm
trying to release it in December or
January you've sold seven million plus
books what advice do you have and he
gave me a whole bunch of fantastic
advice step by step his process to
selling books one of them that was
particularly helpful was having a
Facebook group as a launch Team so
people who bought his book joined the
launch Team and helped spread the
mission for him and he said that
contributed to a huge chunk of his early
sales and so right away that night I
went and I created my launch Team so if
anybody joins now and it's 50 bucks you
get the first copy of the book you're
gonna get a pack of my entrepreneur
Heroes trading cards you're going to get
an autograph you're going to get access
to me in a weekly live stream on
Facebook just for me and the people
who've pre-ordered the book and I just
implemented it right we'll put the we'll
put the link up here so if you want to
join you can go check it out but we just
implemented that because of of David's
advice because of what he told me
because he said hey how can I help you
and so I need to do a better job of
asking for help as well I need to get
over my fear of people either rejecting
me or feeling that I'm imposing on them
and and it's a goal of mine it's
something that I want to work towards
because if I look at the projects I'm
doing if I look at my new book I'm
pumped for it I think it's going to help
a lot of people the the people who've
read it part of my Beta audience they
say it's the the best book that I've
written and and if I don't ask for help
and I don't get it out there I'm
cheating myself and I'm cheating my
audience I'm cheating the world I'm
cheating you guys and so I need to ask
people for help so this video as much as
as it's for you is for me too I'm gonna
listen to my own advice and make it
happen so I've got a three-step process
that I'm going to use myself that I'd
love for you to try on too see if it
works for you step number one is apply
the Wayne Gretzky rule Wayne Gretzky
famously said you miss 100 of those
shots that you never take right if you
don't take the shot you're not gonna get
a goal so even if it's not gonna work
out even if you get a no great you get
up and you ask again because you're
gonna miss every shot if you don't take
it and this is for me anybody who's
afraid to ask and I remember watching
this fantastic clip from Oprah Winfrey
who she got hit up when she was
successful and she got hit up for
donating to different charities and
donating to different causes and she
always felt like she had to say yes to
people and there was one time when
somebody then asked her for money and
she said no she's like I'm being
stretched too thin I can't commit to
everything and she said no and the guy
who lost her said okay
and she said okay really you're you're
not you you don't hate me like no that's
okay on to the next and so taking that
same approach you know you asked for
help your intentions are good you're not
asking for the world you're asking for a
little bit of help and and then don't
attach significant meaning to it if they
say no or they don't deliver not
everybody's going to be able to help you
out even if they have the ambition or
the intention some people are really
busy I had a guy write to me today who
wants my help in promoting something
that he has coming up and I just have
too much on the go right now with my
thought Leadership Academy and then the
YouTube course coming up and then the
book to be able to do this new joint
venture and commit myself fully to it
and so okay maybe something comes from
the future maybe not
you have to ask and get over the fear
that they're gonna say no because
chances are they won't care that much if
it's a no they still love you they still
want you to be successful and that's
okay
you miss every shot that you don't take
so take your shot set number two is
don't take the yes away from somebody
and so these are this is for the people
who are afraid to impose you're afraid
of imposing yourself on somebody or now
you feel indebted to them and and that
it's a big burden for them
the thing that I always remind myself of
is
maybe they want to help you know I love
helping people when I got on the call
with David he had a really tight window
before he left for Florence and I I
wanted to make it work it's like yes
let's make it work in this time window
I'm pumped to help him just to serve
because because I want to help because I
want to see his message get out there
there's a lot of people who want to help
and if you don't ask you're taking the
yes away from them you're cheating them
you're being selfish you think you're
being selfless you think it's selfish to
ask I think it's actually selfish not to
ask because for some people acts of
service is the greatest thing of all
time for them I love being able to help
David if I didn't reach out maybe he
wouldn't have asked me right and then we
would have missed that great opportunity
together and so by you not reaching out
by you feeling like you're imposing on
them recognize that you might actually
be being extremely selfish and you need
to ask because you're taking the yes
away from them and saying yes to some
things and helping people out for some
people is the greatest thing they love
of all time so don't take the yes away
from them don't assume that it's a no
and then step number three is what would
the boldest version of you do try to
remember that it's what I try to
remember from myself all the time and
yes I've had success and built my
channels to these sizes and sold
businesses but it's still nothing
compared to what I'm capable of and it's
easy to wake up and just stay where you
are right it's easy to wake up and just
stay exactly where you are I want to do
more I want to be bigger I want to be
bolder I want to I want to solve the
world's biggest problem you know I need
to remind myself of that consistently
and and I don't do a good enough job of
it to be honest on a daily basis it's
not every single day that I'm feeling
Unstoppable and massively bold and so
having that reminder for myself too is
what would the boldest version of you do
you're afraid to do this you're afraid
to ask this person what would the
boldest version of you do
and I asked myself that and then I do it
so a quick example for my last tour I
was doing this tour 23 cities 90 days
and we're trying to figure out
Transportation how we're going to go
around and I wrote the granite Cardone
friend of the channel done a lot of
videos together and I said hey Grant can
I have your jet for 90 days to tour
around
and I'll promote you right we'll do that
as an exchange it costs a lot just jet
the fuel the pilots all that it's a lot
of money and what would the Bolton's
version of me do so I would ask great so
I wrote the Grant and he responded back
and to his credit said what's the upside
that was his response a quick short
email what is the upside and instead of
just saying no which which you probably
should have uh he just said what's the
upside and I told him hey I'll talk
about you and my audience and everybody
will know your name and it wasn't a big
enough upside so he said no awesome and
we rented a Suburban we drove across
America but you may not win all those
battles you may not get a yes every time
right since then Grant and I have done a
lot of different things together more
videos together more content promoting
each other that one no doesn't destroy
the relationship but being bold being
willing to ask the question even if the
most likely outcome is no it's only the
most likely outcome and if you keep
asking just back to the Wayne Gretzky
rule somebody's gonna say yes so ask
yourself not just for this situation but
in general but with the boldest version
of you do what would the version of you
that would make yourself proud do and
then go do that
[Music]
if you want to see 10 more rules for me
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there